[Applause]
yamaneika this bitch look like she got
all big toes
[Applause]
some of them piggies went to the market
some of them had roast beef and the rest
of them have to have Golden Corral
[Applause]
so it's typical you come with fat jokes
nigger from the Black Lagoon Jamar's so
black his mom didn't even know she was
pregnant with his ass because he kept
showing up as a tumor on the ultrasound
yamaneika bitch your name literally
sounds like some ghetto ass tires
yo we all got no mojo kahana's but we
got these yamaneika Stu 420
[Applause]
such a wack nigger
I'm surprised you in the way because
nigga we know you can't swim
[Applause]
Iram be sincere for a moment Jamar and I
have a lot in common
we were both molested as a child the
only difference is my molester came
[Applause]
whoo yes she got molested when she was
five that's the last time anybody was
feeling her
[Applause]
bitch you'll so big a hunchback
comes out every morning a ringette
clitoris to wake you up wake up bitch
just time to rush battle wake up bitches
time to roast battle Jamal you look like
your dad said Beetlejuice three times
before he came
[Applause]
oh let's joke bitch look at them wide
ass nostrils on yo face this bitch
literally got a sawed-off nose one time
in the early 90s she rode down her car
window to sneeze and accidentally shot
Ricky from boys in the hood
[Applause]
again
my nigga need a lot of props
Martin Lawrence and drag has done more
for big black women in comedy than she
ever will you should have quit while he
was ahead nigga first of all shut the
up you look like something my
hour after I heat up the dollar menu
shut up know all these squawking
ain't gonna work nigga Jamar's mom was a
junkie that's why he got
molested she was too busy putting crack
in a pipe to stop his uncle from putting
a pipe in his crack
[Applause]